before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
ah you know i think i'm just going to
have a nice relaxed day and i
guess not
[Music]
so i figured the announcement of the
next doctor was
rapidly approaching
um i suspect in terms of the timing
given that they didn't have like uh like
an interview uh ready to go the way they
did with say matt smith uh they didn't
have like a teaser video the way they
did with jody whitaker they didn't even
have like a big sort of on stage
presentation or something like they had
with peter capaldi to me says that they
were trying to get ahead of a leak
uh it it feels like a little bit of a
rushed announcement but
it is what it is it's been announced and
i yeah i'm gonna talk about this now if
i'm lucky
i'll get this out the same day i know i
said on twitter that i wouldn't but like
maybe i will
and if this comes out monday morning
well i didn't in any case
we have our 14th doctor
shooti gatwa
and uh that that is at
that's as close as i'm gonna get to
pronouncing it correctly i did like look
it up and do my best but
this is an actor who i'm not familiar
with
he is at this point apparently best
known as one of the leading roles in the
netflix series sex education which is
not something that i've been watching
most of his experience seemed to be on
stage um prior to that and i did
i did look up and like try to watch the
first episode of sex education
i didn't get very far into it not
because it's bad but like
it's a high school somewhat cringey
teenage aimed
romp comedy thing like that's not my bag
about four times over i did watch a
little bit of his performance but i
realized really quickly this is not
useful for me because uh you know at
least as far as season one goes he was a
26 year old playing a teenager
um and that really did not feel like it
was going to give me any indication of
what else he might do and i have no
reason to believe he would play it the
way that he did in sex education so
i stopped pretty quickly because
this isn't helpful
um i did however uh look up an interview
that he did in relation to sex education
the main thing i picked up there was
that the accent he uses in sex education
is not his standard accent but i also
would not have guessed that it wasn't
his standard accent so that immediately
kind of brings the question well
how is he going to choose to sound now
if you're curious about his background
if you know nothing about him he was
born in rwanda but he grew up in
scotland and he's been living in london
while he you know actually has a career
so
i would i
at least would still consider him
british by the same token that i
consider myself to be a vermonter yes
technically i was born in california but
like
i didn't grow up there i grew up here so
other people might get
up weirdly uppity about it or think that
i'm breaking my normal rule of i've i
believe very firmly they should have a
british actor as uh the doctor i would
consider him to be but
that's me here's like here's something
worth i should point out now none of
this video is going to be me talking
about anybody else's response to this
casting i do not have the time and i
sure as hell don't have the energy to
look at what the general reaction has
been i know a little bit about what some
reactions have been like from the
council of geeks discord patreon perk
support me on patreon you can have
access to that let's get the let's get
the plug in there early um or you know a
couple of small things like that
but i'm certainly not seeking out
what the general public is saying i
haven't watched anybody else's videos on
this and
i may not
even after i get this out there just
cause
i don't know
trying to parse what everyone else
thinks about something is draining for
me and it's not something i generally
enjoy doing but uh in any case that will
be no part of this
video so
i know that i had expressed in an
earlier video
actually probably at several points but
i even had a video dedicated to it that
what i really wanted
was for joe martin to be the 14th doctor
now
this was not the point at which i
realized that wasn't going to happen the
point at which i realized that wasn't
going to happen
was when it was announced that joe
martin was going to have a
box set
with big finish playing the fugitive
doctor and as a rule big finish doesn't
get access to the lead actors while
they're currently on the show you know
later guest spots notwithstanding so
that pretty much eliminated her right
there not that it was that likely that
she was going to continue to play the
part anyway because she probably
originally only took the gig on the
basis that it was not going to be eating
up a ton of her time like playing it as
the lead would be so
that i kind of already moved on from now
let's kind of deal with what are
ultimately the two main uh questions or
things that kind of come up culturally
and contextually with this casting the
fact that we have gone from jody
whitaker
back to a man and the fact that
shotigatoa is going to be playing the
first ever
black doctor in the main line as the
lead not the first black doctor joe
martin gets to have that title so don't
take that from her however the first one
who will actually be the lead of the
show as it airs so that is pretty
significant because
while i never want to diminish joe
martin's impact in the role
there is a difference between someone
who is effectively a guest appearance
and actually having it be the lead there
is a difference in the
momentousness of that to a certain
degree not to say that this is more
momentous but it's just it's a different
milestone than the one that joe martin
broke
so you don't break milestones you reach
milestones you break
boundaries and you i
mixing my terminology in my metaphor so
i'm actually i'm i've kind of got
i've kind of gotten mixed feelings about
this i've already seen some people
express
a concern or frustration that
immediately going back to um a
man
to play the doctor
is uh is a sign that we will probably
not get another woman again for a very
very long time because
uh it it people
people feel that it will be read or
interpreted either by
fandom in general or by the people
running the show as an admission that a
female doctor didn't work so we're not
gonna do that again i don't personally
read it as that now
at this point in time we don't know a
lot about what the casting process was
like we don't know if russell t davis
actually just met with actress to see
who was available whether auditions were
held how open those were in terms of the
variety of actors from different
demographics that were brought in we
flat out do not know any of that so i'm
not going to speculate on it so let's
just look at the reality of who we have
and the overall sort of appearance and
how things sort of look or or shake out
when you break down sort of the cultural
impact or the possible interpretations
of that again not getting into
speculating about how casting did or
didn't work because we don't know
all options are possible and i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna throw out 50
different freaking hypotheticals
so
i do understand the concern about having
a man just take over the role
immediately after jody whitaker it's
actually one that i've expressed before
i did a video a while back
talking about my concerns and my feeling
that the next doctor should also be a
woman however a couple of things had
changed since i did that
and the main one being
joe martin now that's not me saying well
we've had another female doctor because
as much as i love joe martin and i never
want to take away the impact of her
reveal and how good she was on the part
for the limited time she's played it
at the same time that's not being like
oh it's another female doctor it's not
the same and i do realize that but the
reason i bring up joe martin is because
if we were to have
another female doctor
well
then
there is
the question of race
because if we were to have another white
woman right away
there would be i think potentially
concern that that would look like
they're trying to basically take another
crack at they're trying to do a redo
on jody whitaker or that it's like well
you know they finally cracked the gender
thing when they went with with someone
other than a man but how long will it be
until we'll have someone who isn't white
and if they went with a black woman
specifically even if joe martin was
never on the table to come in it would
kind of feel like well
why don't you just give us joe martin so
i could see potential just issues or
debates or
uh issues with perception going with
another woman and basically any
variation thereof now that is not me
saying and it's a good thing they didn't
cast a woman i'm not saying that i'm
simply looking at the angles through
which and the lenses through which i
think
this would have been viewed had that
happen now i think the absolute worst
thing they could have done was go back
to a white man and just lock back into
that because that really would have felt
like an admission that any diversity
from that template was a mistake and
however you feel about chibnall zera i'm
not a fan the fact that it was a woman
cast is
not the problem with literally any of it
so
if anything that feeds into that
perception is a potential problem but i
think at least breaking it up so it's
not another white man doesn't feel like
oh we gotta go back to what it was ah
besides the fact that bringing back
russell t davis already has a little bit
of the feeling of we need to go back to
when it worked before you don't need to
double down and do that with the casting
of the doctor as well
now it's worth touching on at least the
idea really quickly that maybe you know
they could have gotten another actress
who is non-white but isn't specifically
black except there was the conv i i now
kind of have a better understanding
about the reality of the demographics
particularly in the acting community uh
in the uk i have my discussion with
jason hey gallery who is the managing
director at big finish you can check
that interview out there if you want and
one of the things we actually spent a
while about was talking about uh the
demographics of the available actors
because something i hadn't appreciated
something he didn't necessarily
understand um was viewed differently in
other parts of the world is that i'm
used to
looking at casting diversity from the
metrics of casting in the u.s where most
casting is done in places like los
angeles and new york which are
incredibly diverse cities in an already
pretty dang diverse country whereas in
the uk
the percentage of not only the general
population is way way way wider but
the percentage of working actors is also
disproportionately white even even
relative to the uh demographics of the
country as a whole and uh any uh
minority that isn't black is even less
represented regardless of what their
actual um standing uh in terms of
population in
in the nation there is so like er
trying to deliberately cast
uh non-white i don't think is a bad
thing but i now have better
understanding of how difficult that can
be in the uk because especially for
something like this trying to find
somebody who is
up for it
talented
and more importantly available
i mean that's difficult for anybody but
when you narrow your field of potential
actors um because you're looking for
something specific that makes it all the
harder
but
anyway there's that tangent gun so
that's me talking about sort of the
general
look of having gone from jody whitaker
to shootigatoa going from a woman to a
man but also now going to
a black man which if they were gonna go
back to a man
i am definitely glad they didn't go with
another white guy because as i said that
would have been the well no the worst
thing would have been to bring back an
actor who'd already played it stop
pushing the idea of david tennant coming
back my god
duh and i like i don't think that was
ever on the table and i never thought it
was but it really frustrated me how many
people kept saying that that would or
should happen
and i'm also kind of heartened by the
fact that
i didn't see shiri gatwa
show up on any of the lists
uh of a lot of likely people i saw like
every now and then and i don't monitor
this stuff but every now and then people
would shoot me like oh the bookmakers
now say it's probably gonna be this or
the the site that um claimed it was
gonna be jody whitaker and was right
about that it says it's going to be this
person or like i would see those names i
never saw his name anywhere
and that's kind of nice
i can't help but be reminded a bit about
matt smith not just because matt smith
was a pretty unknown now i actually
think [ __ ] to god was got a better and
more established career at this point
than matt smith did when he was cast but
like at least for me my experience of
finding out who it was
not knowing
who this person is and also how young he
is
because he is a little bit older than
matt smith was when matt smith was cast
but
he's pretty young
he's he'll be
he'll be 30 by the time he starts
actually shooting
um
most likely he'll either be 30 or he'll
turn 30 during the sh the shooting of
his first series
and it's been a while since we've had
somebody that young
and i don't think that's automatically a
better thing
um and i also don't think it
automatically means he's gonna bring a
quote-unquote youthful energy to things
because one of the things that was
actually really intriguing about matt
smith was despite his clear visible
youth he had the sense of somebody much
older
so
i'm not saying that this gives me a read
on how he'll play the doctor i have
truly
zero idea how he is going to play the
doctor
but
i am sort of
energized
from what i am coming to understand
about him seeing his youth watching an
interview with him seeing the energy
that he just has as a person
not really liking what i saw sex
education but again seeing um
just a natural charisma which is uh in
my mind a good thing to see and
something i i like to have
uh in my doctors when i can get them and
seeing that and and again hearing you
know how different his natural accent is
from the one he uses in sex education so
i don't even know what he's going to
sound like it's
just kind of thrilling to
have a face
but really wonder
what are we gonna get
i'm curious
and
while i never believed
any of the rumors especially of like
david tennant
there's something
relieving
about i don't have even a tiny sliver of
my brain worried about are they going to
announce somebody that's going to make
me worried
they've now announced who it is
i'm not worried
i'm not assuming he's gonna be great
because like i said i have no idea how
he's gonna play this part at all but at
least knowing that they're not gonna
cast somebody who's gonna fall into you
know any number of things that i was
afraid of you know going back
uh to a white man you feel like it's
capitulating to certain fan demands or
any number or
especially going back to an actress
played before or anything like that now
that i know that it's truly impossible
even though i believed it before like i
now know for a fact none of that happens
i can kind of relax and just
wait till we see more i think probably
next video from me on this
will be when we get
uh a look at the outfit because i if
we're going by the template set by jody
whitaker's announcement which again it's
already slightly broken because she had
like the like the reveal video thing and
should he go to what
doesn't get that but if we assume a
general template along those lines
next up we can uh assume we'll get some
kind of promotional material be it video
or
um or
photographs of
the outfit
and
how he's gonna look and then i might
start to get a better sense of how he's
going to play the part once i know how
he's going to be costumed and then we'll
wait for teasers and trailers
and then new episodes
i'm just
relieved i think that's where i'm at
um
it's just an announcement that i'm like
okay
okay
yeah
show me what you got
my thoughts on the casting of shruti
gatwa as the doctor
what are your thoughts on this whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it like share
subscribe mention the patreon already
but um even if you can't support me
there
all the other stuff helps me out as well
and there's links in the description to
books i've written or merch that is
available or other places that you can
see things that i do
but don't worry too much about it
because what i really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters imudelkey the oath the boy tt
for knobby lax the poodle zac paul idoln
tracy scrappet vincent paul bartolucci
angry casper toku blhovian adam rdl
taylor shane ross shayla gourlay and
brendan larose you want to hear me
mispronounce your name check out rewards
on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]